[THEME MUSIC PLAYING]
SOPHIA YANG: Welcome, everyone.
Thank you so much
for being here today.
Especially thank you because
this is the last session
of the last day.
It's a three-days'
conference, so pretty long--
a lot of work.
And we are very excited see
you still stay here today.
And that's the right choice.
Because, actually, when we
first got the schedule, they say
we're the very last one.
We actually asked, can
we get moved to the day
before, et cetera, so
more people might attend?
But then say, no, you can't.
We can't because you're
talk is too important.
And the order of the talks
are ordered by the increasing
of the importance.
So we're the last one.
But you'll be happy to find
out that's it's important
that you made it, right?
Well, make sure you learn
a lot of important things.
You'll find it very
helpful so that you
can end your conference
on the strongest note.
My name is Sophia Yang, product
manager from the Compute Engine
team.
Joining me today are
three gentlemen here.
We have Cache, our developer
from the Cloud Security team.
And we have Sirui, also product
manager from Compute Engine
team.
And we have Nick from
Two Sigma, our customer,
to join us to tell us the
story about how Two Sigma is
utilizing our tools to build
their most secure environment.
So privacy and
security has always
been the top priority at Google.
We're going to help you build
the most secure environment.
And that's why every
year we continuously
invest in building new
features, new tools
to help you achieve that goal.
And it's worth
mentioning, not only
we're building this new
environment for you guys,
we're also using this ourselves.
Many products,
applications from Google
are also running
on Google Cloud.
And today, we're making
our secret sauce, our best
practice, our perspectives
into six simple steps
to walk you through,
step-by-step,
how to build the most
secure environment.
And when talking
about getting started,
before we share any
best practice yet, let's
just first look at
how people mostly
get started with the cloud.
We find out no matter you
are one of the Fortune 500
company with
thousands of employees
or you're just an individual
developer, often when you
get started with
Google Cloud, you
want to first start by trying
out the new, cool features,
testing out the performance.
And at that phase, performance--
access management is the last
thing you want to worry about.
And we understand that.
That is why we make
the "getting started"
stage super simple
and easy for you.
You come to Google Cloud,
or you create a project,
you automatically are
the owner of the project
and you have full access
within the project.
You don't have to worry
too much about who
can access the resource
because your project is created
as an isolated
environment, so no one else
can access your resources
within the project.
All this is trying
to minimize your time
to finish your proof of concept,
to finish your prototype,
so make sure you can totally
fall in love with Google Cloud.
And then when you're done
with your prototype, what
do you do next?
You're ready to move
your production workload,
right, your development
testing environments onto us.
And that is when
we should started
talking about how to build
the most secure environment.
And that takes us a step
one, create an organization.
So why is creating an
organization so important?
Because afterwards,
it's much easier
to apply
organizational-wide policy
if you have an organization.
And in talking about
building an organization,
the first thing you
need to do is to set up
your organizational identity.
And so let's see
Cache here to tell
us more about how to do that.
CACHE MCWHERTER: Thanks, Sophia.
The first things
that you need to do
to get any kind of
security for your cloud
is to essentially
root your trust
in the identities
in your system.
Without securing your identities
and the identities that
can access your
resources, there really
is no hope in securing
the rest of your cloud.
And that means that you
need an identity store,
you need an identity provider,
and you need policies
that you can apply
to those identities.
Here at Google,
we have solutions
to get you started here for
no matter what kind of company
you are.
And the first way that you--
and two general paths in which
you can establish your identity
store at Google.
The first is to use Google as
your identity provider itself.
And I'm sure that many
of you do this already.
Google does this internally.
We use our products
internally all the time.
The basic is a fully-fledged
identity system
with groups, and users,
and APIs to manage them,
security controls, and
so forth, and so on.
And it's also conveniently
very easy to set up
for small customers
of Google Cloud.
If you're an established
shop, and you
have an existing identity
system, such as Active
Directory, or an
LDAP system, you
can use Google
Cloud Directory Sync
to synchronize those
identities and groups to Google
and use them and apply them in
policies in the Google Cloud
product.
The next thing, after you
establish your identity store
at Google Cloud, you need
to secure them somehow.
And fortunately at
Google, we've basically
been working on securing
clouds for many, many years
now, first with our
internal cloud product
but also for now with our
external cloud products.
We've been dealing with attacks
on our internal resources
and our customers'
resources from state
actors, non-state actors.
You name it, we've
probably seen it.
And we have a lot of researchers
and security engineers just
tracking all of the
instances that we
can find of things maybe
the rest of the world
hasn't even discovered yet.
And we then also work on trying
to mitigate those attacks
with new tooling and
features that sometimes we
apply internally but
then sometimes we
give to you to apply
to your own resources.
And I'm going to give
you a list of basically
a few of the things that I think
that you should be turning on
basically out of the box for
ensuring that your cloud is
secure.
The first thing I
want to talk about
is two-factor authentication
and security keys.
We have been using
these internally
for a couple of years now.
And they have been super
effective at eliminating
all sorts of account attacks
and phishing attacks.
The basic idea is that
your users get a--
your developers
get a security key.
And this is a hard to
phish security device
that has to be present every
time that your users log in,
your developers log in.
And so what that means
is that if someone
can steal my password or trick
me into answering questions,
an attacker can't
actually log in
unless they're in possession
of the security device as well.
To configure your
systems to use this,
you can go to the Google
Cloud Admin console,
and you can go to
the security settings
and turn on the security keys.
This is so important.
We've actually just announced
our own security key products,
which should be coming to market
at some point in the future.
The second thing, after
you've secured your accounts
themselves, is to secure
your connected applications
to your identities.
I'm sure all of you have seen
the news with various incidents
that basically, if a third-party
application can connect
to your users and get their
data from a cloud provider,
it's unclear what that
third-party provider
might do with the data.
And this means that this
is one situation when
you have your social media data
being collected by an attacker,
by a third-party company.
It's another thing entirely when
it's your corporate resources
that are being stolen.
And basically, in these
situations, your developers,
you just need to trick one
developer in your company
to install an application
on their phone
or on their browser,
and all of a sudden,
access to your corporate
resources could be granted.
So we highly recommend that you
go to the Google main console
and turn off all
connected applications
for all scopes on all APIs
that are important to you,
in particular for the Google
Cloud Platform, maybe others.
And then at some point,
if you need to actually
have developers delegate
access to applications,
either first-party applications
or applications from vendors
you trust, you can vet
those applications,
and you can use the
trusted app configuration
tools to whitelist individual
apps to have access
to individual services.
Now, I think I know what most
of you people are now thinking.
You're probably thinking,
this is great, Cache,
but the thing that really
keeps we awake at night
are the attackers working from
their undersea lairs trying
to get access to my cloud.
I want to tell you
that I, too, worry
about these kinds of situations.
And we just announced the other
day our new set of security
features around protecting
access to your cloud resources
to what we call Secure
Contacts or Access Contacts.
And the basic idea is
that I can configure it
in my Cloud Console the
set of networks or VPNs
that should have access
to my cloud resources
and essentially
mitigate and prevent
accesses to my resources from
outside of those networks.
And the good thing about
this is not only does it
help mitigate against attacks
from deep sea, undersea lairs,
it also helps protect
from attackers in volcano
fortresses, or even moon bases.
And the final thing I want to
tell you about organizations
in Google Cloud is that they
give you an incredibly powerful
tool to organize and manage
your resources in a way that
makes sense to your business.
In particular, we find that
organizations are often
broken up into
individual product areas
and sometimes with different
types of deployments.
For instance, internally
at Google, we often
speak about dev-level
environments,
staging-level environments, and
production-level environments.
And you can actually
model these things
in folders and
different projects
and apply policies that
apply it down hierarchically
through the policy
hierarchy, essentially,
so that you can apply a
policy high in the policy
tree and to apply to all
resources underneath.
Or for instance,
if something makes
sense only for a
specific product area,
you can apply a policy
to only the resources
within that product area.
And with that, I'd like
to turn over to Sophia
to teach us about step two.
SOPHIA YANG: All right.
Thank you so much, Cache.
So now, great.
You have set up
your organization,
you have synced out a set of all
your organization identities,
or synced your
identity from on-prem.
So now you realize
you have thousands
of employees on cloud.
So how can you manage
that access of them?
How you make sure the right
person can perform their job,
like your developers
can go ahead,
deploy code in our codebase?
Also, you don't give everyone
a super power role, right?
And that is when you need to
set up your identity and access
management, or most
people call it IAM.
So IAM am in a
nutshell is really
about giving you the control
to set who can perform which
actions on what resources.
So in an actual
example, for example,
I can say I want to grant
Cache the instance admin
role to my test project.
That's going to allow
Cache to manipulate
my instances in
the test project,
right, create the et cetera.
I can also grant, say,
Sirui the storage admin
role in my project,
the same project.
And Sirui can then
access my data
that I stored in a GCS bucket.
Yet, Sirui wouldn't be
able to manipulate my VM
instance because he's
not instance admin.
The same thing,
Cache wouldn't be
able to access the GCS bucket
unless they coordinate, right?
But the good thing, that's
what IAM can allow you,
a fine granular control
of who can do what.
So then now you
probably can realize,
wow, I have thousands
of employees.
The policy sounds like it
will look very complicated.
Don't panic.
No matter how and the result
might look complicated,
the steps you are taking
out of the set of the IAMs
are always the same.
The policy language
is always the same.
Which of the steps
you will follow
is first create a IAM policy and
then set the policy on a target
resource.
So let's first look at what
an IAM policy looks like.
Here is a JSON example.
As you can tell, policy
contains a list of bindings.
And so within each binding,
you define members and rules.
And in this example,
all these members
are assigned with the
same image user role.
So let's take a deeper
look at the members, which
is the circled part.
We allow three types of
identities at Google Cloud.
One is the users, which
are the human users, two,
service accounts, who are the
identities of VMs, services,
so they are the
representation for robots,
pretty much, and the
groups, obviously
the group of multiple things.
And you can put both human
users and the service accounts
into one group.
And next, lastly,
we have the roles.
The roles, or IAM
roles, which is really
a collection of permissions.
So let's take a deeper
look at what roles can be.
At Google, we support
three types of IAM roles.
The first two types
are primitive roles
and the predefined roles.
There are three types within the
primitive roles, only three--
owner, editor, and the viewers.
They each have very wide
access and very wide sets
of permissions.
They are meant to-- remember
we set a "get started" state?
Well, they are meant to
get you started quickly.
But yet, they're
really not meant
for production for
exactly the same reason.
They are too coarse.
They each have too wide
access of the permissions.
So what should you use
in production system?
Predefined roles or sometimes
called the curated roles.
What are they?
They are just really
fine-grained roles
that Google defined for you
that's specifically targeting
your specific use case.
For example,
instance admin roles
are most likely mapped to your
developer functionalities.
And the network
admin, probably you'll
give to your network
admin, as the name sounds,
to help you setup the
network's firewalls,
VPNs before a developer
comes to deploy code.
And our best practice
there is always
use the least privileged role.
So do not grant any additional
permissions unless needed.
That's for your
security purposes.
And in order to better
implement this least
privileged principle,
we also have
a third type of IAM roles,
which is custom IAM roles.
We made this offering publicly
available earlier this year.
As the name suggests,
it's allowing
you to customize
what permissions
you want to precisely
put into your role.
So there are two
typical use cases
that you need to
use custom IAM role.
One is the-- you might realize
our predefined roles are still
too limited.
Some customers
are saying, I have
to sometimes assign two
or three predefined roles
to each identity
to do their job.
And if I scale, it's a
little harder to manage.
Many people on SRE used to
have both log viewer roles
and monitor viewer
roles in this example.
So then you can create
your own custom role
to combine these
two roles together.
And then going
forward, you can just
assign this particular
custom role.
Another use case
is the opposite.
Some customers find out our
predefined roles are still
too wide or it
doesn't necessarily
meet exactly their
business needs.
A popular example will
be instance admin role.
They want to give it
to their developer.
They want everything about it
except the external IP usage
for exfiltration, infiltration.
So they don't want
the developers
to be able to create a
VM with the external IP.
So they would just easily remove
that particular permission
from the existing role and
create their own developer
admin role.
And next, since we learn
about IAM policies, roles,
and identities, let's
talk about a few
best practices of
how to implement
those in the most secured way.
The first recommendation
we give to you
is always assigning permission
and access to groups, not
to individual users.
So why is that?
I know it's very natural
to think about, oh, I
have roles we should assign
to those users directly.
But think about your
employees could move around
within a company.
If you're directly giving
them roles, permissions
on themselves,
after a while, you
might realize it's
harder to track,
to understand what permissions
this employee currently
still need.
Maybe he was in a different
group and needed something
else, but now he doesn't.
But after a while,
it's very hard
to analyze so that you
couldn't achieve the least
privileged principle, right?
But different, if you can assign
permissions directly onto group
and then add or remove
users from groups,
say, so one employee
leave a certain group,
they get removed
from that group,
they automatically lose
all those permissions
they had before.
It's much easier and
cleaner to manage
the access for employees.
And at the same time,
service accounts
do not change roles and
move around as the humans.
So we recommend you
directly set the policies
on service accounts.
So that's the first
principle and also
best practice, grant
access to groups.
Here's another one that we
have seen a lot of success
from our customers, which
is break-glass style.
One of the approach is--
by the way, if you are not
familiar with this term,
think about fire distinguisher
on the wall, right?
They are protected by the glass
so that if there is a fire,
you can access by
breaking the glass.
But that's a very
invasive action.
Takes a lot of additional
caution to do it.
And by doing so,
you're preventing
a lot of accidental errors.
So one of the styles to
implement this break-glass
is to assign human users nothing
but the project IAM admin role.
What this particular role only
allows is set permissions,
set policies.
That's it.
So if you give your on-call
this particular role,
they wouldn't be able
to just go ahead,
stop your VM in production
system, because they can't.
They don't have the permission.
But yet, as we said, it's
called a break glass.
So if emergency arises, if
there is an urgent situation,
they do have to go ahead and
manipulate their VM instance.
They can use their
project IAM admin role
to grant themselves the
instance admin role.
And from there,
they can go ahead
and manipulate the VM instance.
But then this extra layer of
caution and actual requirements
can help you prevent a
lot of accidental actions.
And by the way, all these change
of policies, setting policies,
are in the auto-log, so you
can go back to trace that.
And with that, I'm
sure many of you
already have questions,
want to know more
about service accounts.
So let's invite Cache
back to tell more
about service accounts.
CACHE MCWHERTER: Thanks.
As most of you guys
know, service accounts
are quite fun toys to play with.
They tirelessly execute
all of our actions for us
when we're not there
at the keyboard.
They run our jobs, they run our
services, they never get paid,
and yet they're
always there for us.
But sometimes they're
hard to understand.
And so I'd like
to first help you
get to know what the service
accounts that we offer
look like, and feel like,
and how to differentiate them
and make sense of them
as you encounter them.
This is a common cause
of confusion and errors
that we see when we talk
to our external customers.
This is an IAM policy page that
you see in the Google Cloud
Developer console.
This is the landing page
when you get to IAM.
As you can see,
this IAM indicates
this is an IAM policy.
This is the policy
that grants access
to this project and all the
resources contained within.
As Sophia was
indicating earlier,
policy is essentially
just a mapping
of the sets of permissions
to a set of identities.
So for instance, this one
grants me owner on this project.
This is a service account.
You can tend to identify
them by the fact
that they end in
gserviceaccount.com email
addresses.
The name here
indicates what it is.
It's a service account
that was created
by default by the system to
get me started using the cloud.
It has editor access,
which is fairly powerful.
And clearly this is not a
production project, right?
Everything that we told
you before about securing
your projects was not done
here, and so you can imagine
what that might look like here.
You've taken
cache@google.com off.
You've granted him
project IAM admin.
You've taken--
well, you actually
granted him project IAM
admin through his presence
on a team called Team David.
The service account
at the top has
been granted Cloud Datastore
user because all he is doing
is accessing Datastore,
for instance.
And so this makes sure that
if that job is compromised,
the impact and blast radius
is limited to the Datastore
and not, for instance,
my VMs or other things.
These other service
accounts here in the middle
are a common cause of
confusion for our customers.
They represent the
identities of services
activated and essentially
purchased from Google.
I didn't create them,
I don't own them,
and I don't manage them.
They're owned and managed by
Google and protected for you.
They're kept securely under lock
and key for only our production
services to access.
They've been granted particular
API access to your resources
in this project.
And they specifically
grant access
to only the types of
data and operations
that are in line
with the business
requirements of those services.
And we basically review
every one of those security
grants-- every one
of those grants
before we allow them to be
granted to your projects
to make sure that they
actually make logical sense
and meet your expectations.
If I wanted to look at
the service accounts
that I own and I manage, you
can flip to the service account
tab.
And here, you can see that I
have two service accounts, one,
the default one
that we told you was
created earlier by the system
for me to get me started.
But I also created another one
called My Web FE, which I am
using to run my web front end.
There are two ways that you
can use these service accounts.
The first way is
to use what we call
Google-Managed Credentials,
which essentially means
that you don't have
to worry about any
of the key management
or the rotation story.
We keep the service
accounts secure for you.
It's a tireless task, but
somebody's got to do it.
They don't pay me
enough to do that,
but we make sure that they
always get rotated for you.
And they're kept secure.
The basic idea here is
that I can ask a service,
like Google Compute, or Google
App Engine, or Google Cloud
Functions to use a
service account here.
I'm asking, for
instance, Compute Service
to create an instance bound to
my front end service account.
And what happens
is an actAs check--
a permission called actAs
will be checked to make sure
that I have permission to
use the service account
and bind it to a job.
And then once I've
been granted access,
that job will run
continuously without me being
there as that service account.
And that VM, the
code inside the VM,
can go and access
data commiserate
with the permissions
that have been
granted to the service account.
The other way of
using service accounts
is to download a
service account key.
And this is a less
secure, we think,
way of managing your
service accounts
and using your service
accounts, because you
have to take responsibility
for making sure
that key doesn't leak.
And you have to take
responsibility for rotating
that key to keep it secure.
It's predominantly
there for you to use
when connecting your on-premise
systems to Google Cloud
Platform.
For instance, if you needed to
do database backup, or computer
backup, or something like
this to Cloud Storage,
you could use a service
account key to do that.
Many of you are Google
Compute customers, I'm sure.
And you've seen in the user
interfaces, and the APIs,
and the command lines
that, when you create VMs,
we often ask you for a set of
access control scopes, which
are scopes when
you're creating a VM.
We call these VM lock
scopes, essentially.
They're a legacy feature
of Compute from the days
before Google IAM
came on the scene.
They caused some confusion
to our customers.
And so I'd like to clarify
some of the usage here.
They used to be used for some
course-grained access control,
but they're not really
good for that these days.
So we highly recommend
that, in general,
when you see these things,
you should close your eyes
and don't use them
for access control.
Rely on IAM for access control.
And instead, give the VM
a fairly high-level scope,
such as Google Cloud
Platform or full access
depending on the user
interface you're using.
And if you need to call
other APIs, like Calendar,
or Maps, or something, you can
grant those scopes as well.
And I think Sophia has
something more to tell you
about managing your resources.
SOPHIA YANG: Yep.
All right.
Thank you, Cache.
Yeah.
So now we have got our
employee imported here
in the Google Cloud and a set
of IAM policies onto them,
also set up additional
IAM permissions
onto the service accounts.
So now what's left to do?
You are going to come here
to create a VM instance,
right, creating disks as images.
How you make sure you
manage the access to those,
to secure those resources?
And that's what this
section is we're
going to be talking about.
So let's have a quick review
of what Cache showed earlier
about our policy hierarchies.
At Google, we offer four levels
of hierarchies-- organization,
folders, projects,
and the resources.
So you can set up permissions,
policies on each of a level,
and any level down below will
automatically inherit it.
So for example, if I want to
give architect the image user
role for all of the
team A, so then I
can go ahead and set that
policy on the folder level,
team A. Then this architect
will automatically
become the image user role for
all the project A, project two,
and et cetera, any
projects under the folder.
So this give you a lot
of flexibility to use.
But sometimes you might
want the opposite.
You actually want to run
into the situation you only
want to give access to
a particular resource
instead of grant
it a higher level.
So what would you do there?
You can set the policies
onto the individual resource,
like VMs, disks.
But probably, many people are
familiar with Compute Engine
IAM.
You might ask me, I didn't know
that you were able to do so.
I thought, at the
lowest level, you
can't set a policy with
the projects level.
And you are right
until this week.
We're actually
very excited to let
you know that we are going
to support resource-level IAM
in beta very soon for you guys.
[APPLAUSE]
Highly anticipated
feature, it seems like.
Great.
And what it allows
you to do is exactly
to set IAM policies on
individual resource,
like VMs, disks.
This totally enables a
whole new set of use cases.
For example, a common use case
is, within an organization,
people often like
to share images
with other developers
or different users.
Yet, without the
resource-level IAM,
they have to give the image
user role for the whole project
or above, right?
But sometimes you do
want to give them access
to all the image, just
the production imagery.
Before resource-level
IAM, what you had to do
was create a separate
project, and only
put that particular
image in that project,
and then grant policies
onto the project level.
That's suboptimal and a lot
of management overhead, right?
So was this
resource-level IAM, you
can simply just
grant the IAM policy
onto the particular image.
In this example here, I
want to grant the beta test
group the access to the
particular beta image.
And just by simple one line of
code, you can achieve that now.
So here is a real-world
example of sharing images,
as we were talking about
this scenario, right?
So now you can create
one single image project
and then put in your
production image
together with our beta testing
image in the same project,
and only grant the developers
access to the production image
so to make sure everyone uses
the most supported and verified
version, and giving
the beta testers access
to the beta testing images.
So now you probably
start thinking,
yeah, I can set IAM policies
on each beta testing image
to give the beta testers.
But yet, if I have many
of the beta testing image,
I have to set the policy on
individual image every time.
Would that be a little bit--
a lot of work to do, right?
And we have thought
about that for you.
So if you want to have another
way to manage your resources
access at scale, they
will be happy to find out
another beta feature that's
coming soon to you, which
is name Prefix IAM condition.
What this allows you to do is
exactly manage your resources
under the condition
based on name Prefix.
So let's backtrack a little
bit to talk about what
is conditional IAM first.
As I mentioned
earlier, IAM's allowing
you to define who can do what
on what resources, right?
And now conditional
IAM giving you
additional power, which
is adding a condition now
to the IAM access.
So we wouldn't grant access
unless the condition is also
met.
In this name Prefix
Condition, we
would say, for example, you can
grant beta testers the image
user role on a project, but
only if the image, the name,
is starting with beta.
That way you can achieve
what I just mentioned.
By setting one policy,
the beta testing groups
will have access to all the
images starting with name beta.
And that's even
including the images
that you have yet to create.
As long as you created them
under the beta underscore name,
all your beta testers will
have access to that image.
Another common
use case customers
ask for that you can utilize
this name Prefix Condition is
to build this so-called
Developer Playground.
Many companies, when they
have new developers join in,
they like to put them
all in the same project
to test out, to build
their prototypes,
because creating each one
on individual projects
is a lot of overhead.
Yet, they don't want every
developer to accidentally stomp
upon other people's resource.
So setting up the name
Prefix Condition to base
on each developer's
email address
solves the situation so that
each developer will still
only have access
to the resources
starting with their
names, and yet they
can still be enjoy,
within the same project,
the convenience and also the
high network performance.
More excitingly, you will
find out conditional IAM
not only allow allowing to do
name Prefix Basic Condition.
We have two more type of
conditions we support,
which is access level and
the date time condition.
Access level utilizes the
security context thing
that Cache mentioned earlier--
sorry-- that we will look at
the role attributes coming from
the request, and
then to decide--
even, for example, the
instance admin, say,
you can manipulate
an instance, right
but you can say any
actions to manipulate
the instance for a
production project,
this request needs to come
in from my corp network.
That way even that instance
admin sitting in their home,
trying to do some work, the
request will be rejected,
so giving you another layer
for security and protection.
Date time condition, just
as the name suggests,
it allows you to get a
timer around your condition
so that you can say,
grant a powerful access
to your on-call SREs but only
during their on-call hours.
Before this, you had to
grant access and then
remove access manually at the
end of their on-call time.
But now you can just simply
set up a time-based condition.
And it can be recurring as well.
So we can help you manage that.
All right.
So we talk a lot about
IAMs, conditional IAMs,
resource IAMs to help you
better manage our resources.
Let's talk about
another dimension
and go to how to
manage the access
for your organization, which
is the famous organizational
policy.
Organization policies are
meant to work together side
by side with IAM policies.
But there's a key difference,
which is, org policies,
the enforcement will be there
regardless of IAM access.
So for example, if you
utilize-- the first example
shows no external
IP or org policy.
You can set that on your project
folder or organization level
saying, oh, in my
organization, for example,
I don't allow VMs to be
created with an external IP.
Then even the person
that's supposed
to have that IAM permission,
like computer admins,
wouldn't be able to do so.
So this helps prevent
a lot of human errors.
Again, it's an organizational
policy enforced
at whatever level
you are granted.
And similar as IAM
policy, any level
below will automatically
inherit that.
And Compute Engine will have
a bunch of very useful org
policies that you can read
about, like trusted image,
disable serial-port
access, et cetera.
There are, in particular, two
more organization policies
that we'd like to call out.
And we really think you
should know about them.
And we will highly recommend
you to enable them.
The first one is
domain-restricted
sharing organization policy.
What this is allowing
you to restrict,
the resources wouldn't be
shared outside the organization.
We have seen mistakes done
before from a customer
that, for example, their
developer will go home,
and they're trying
to do some work,
but they accidentally share
this image with their IP.
It was their own Gmail account,
and there is information leak
there.
With this organizational
policy, you
can secure that resources
wouldn't be shared to anywhere
outside your organization.
The next one, Disable Service
Account Keys, this [INAUDIBLE]
back what Cache
mentioned earlier.
We want to have a Google--
we recommend you use Google
to manage the key instead
of user-generated credentials.
And if you enable
this org policy,
it will prevent exactly
user-managed generated key
so that you wouldn't
have long-living keys
that developers
hold and that might
expose additional risk
to your organization,
to your environment.
And we have a bunch more
organization policies
we can introduce for you.
Yet, you can read them
online probably better
than what I can say
each about them.
But I think, more
interesting, you
will be interested to find out
how a real customer, like Two
Sigma, set up and utilize these
IAM policies and organization
policies to build
their environment.
So we're happy to invite
Nick, the head of Cloud
Security at Two Sigma, to
tell us about your story.
[APPLAUSE]
Welcome.
NICK ARVANITIS:
Thank you, Sophia.
Yeah, we're also very
excited about IAM conditions
and conditional roles.
My name's Nick.
Two Sigma-- I'll
talk a little bit
about our business to put our
threat model into context.
We're a technology-driven,
data-driven, quantitative
investment manager.
Really, what that means
is we use computers
to analyze a ton of data
sets and try to make market
decisions based off that.
We're obviously very worried
about external attackers,
though we have a very
small external profile.
So although we're worried
about volcano fortresses,
we're also worried about
our internal users.
And that's not to say that
we don't trust our people.
There's some extent to
which we don't trust them,
but we do trust them.
But if you follow
security and compromises,
you know that sophisticated
attackers are targeting people
with legitimate access to data.
And we have some
sort of friction
whereby we need our
people to have access
to the data and the
resources they need in order
to do their jobs, but then also
mitigate the risk of mistakes
or intentional compromises.
So we want to protect our IP.
And one of the big use cases
we have for Compute Engine
is really as an extension
of our data center.
We run a lot of trading
simulations or model tests
and simulations that
use tons of compute.
And that's not exposed
to the internet at all.
It's in a hybrid-type
environment.
So things like what
Sophia mentioned is we
don't want external IPs
in that environment.
Even though there's no internet
access, mistakes can happen.
And we believe very strongly
in defense in depth.
You don't want to be one error
or one failure of a control,
or one compromise
away from being
on the front page of the
papers or, in our case,
potentially out of business.
So we apply
organization policies
as a really cheap and
easy to implement control,
but with really
powerful implications,
like no external IPs.
Something else that's
really interesting to us
is, a really useful
feature, the ability
to connect to a compute
instance as serial console
if you have a network
outage and troubleshoot it.
Our issue is that that
doesn't take into account
any of our file policies
or network configurations.
So we hate that
and we turn it off.
You can tackle this,
again, via IAM.
But one of our use cases,
again, enabling velocity
for our teams, is
my partner team
that runs this environment
would really hate it
if I didn't allow them the
ability to configure metadata
on VM instances where you
can turn this on or off.
They need that
for bootstrapping.
So a safe compromise is to
use this organization policy
to enforce that
control and then be
able to be more lenient on IAM.
Again, we really want to
be restrictive about what
images we use.
We have a lot of
custom configuration
that goes into those.
So we have-- as suggested
in the best practices,
we have a single project where
our trusted image is built,
and then we use an org policy
to configure our environments
that only images
from that environment
can be booted up and used.
The flip side of that is also
obviously really important.
We, too, have a developer
sandbox, like everybody else.
And we don't want, in
that environment that's
wide open and connected to
the internet, our images that
are baked with our IP
and, in other cases,
sensitive configuration
details to be used at all.
So we use another
org policy for that.
And finally, as
Sophia mentioned,
domain-restricted sharing
really is a no-brainer for us.
It's super easy to implement.
And these things really
provide us a lot of access.
Again, other best
practices, this
is really defense in depth.
We rely very strongly on
using custom IAM roles only.
We tailor our roles
based on least privilege.
And we use a whole host of
other services for our security
posture.
But these offerings and the ones
that have been discussed today
are really essential
for us in terms
of enabling our business without
adding unnecessary friction
either to our security team
or to our client teams.
So with that, I'll hand
to Sirui to wrap up
with the final section of how
to secure your environment.
[APPLAUSE]
SIRUI SUN: Thank you, Nick.
So hi, everyone.
My name is Sirui.
I'm another product
manager on the GCE team.
And actually, first
of all, I want
to say thank you so much, Nick,
for talking with us today.
It's been an absolute
blast and a privilege
to be able to work with
you guys to really secure
your incredibly valuable IP.
So thank you again.
Let's hear another round
for Nick, Two Sigma.
[APPLAUSE]
Great.
So I'm here to take us home and
talk about the final step here
in our six steps best practices.
And I'm here to talk to you
guys about platform transparency
and data integrity.
So you may be wondering,
right, what does that mean?
So to boil it down,
here at Google Cloud,
your trust is our
top priority, right?
We understand that many of
you, many of our customers,
really rely on Google Cloud to
run their businesses, right?
And we know that wouldn't
be possible without having
deep trust in how we
administer our platform.
So the way I think about this
is, when we talk about platform
transparency here,
what we really mean
is, what are the tools and what
is the information that we're
giving you guys as our
customers to really have faith,
and trust, and to really
build that trust in how we're
administering our
platform, right?
And as we'll see that takes
a few different forms.
The first thing I
want to talk about
is how your data is
encrypted, right?
And so before I go
any further, I just
want to say that,
at Google Cloud,
regardless of how you
store your data with us,
we are going to be
encrypting your data
at rest full stop, rihgt?
And in the spirit of
transparency-- thank you,
Cache--
in the spirit of transparency,
you can go online.
If you Google, for example,
Google Cloud Security white
paper, we have a lot of white
papers and other resources
for y'all so that you can
read about our security best
practices in general, how we
do that encryption at rest,
things like that.
So I would highly
encourage all of you,
if you are interested, to go
take a look at that following
this presentation.
What I'm talking about
here is the options
that we give you all in GCE,
in Google Compute Engine,
for how we actually do that
encryption at rest, right?
And so here you see we have
three different options.
So I go left to right.
And they fall in this
spectrum of automation,
so how much control we
give versus how automated
the encryption actually is.
So we'll start with the one on
the left, which is encryption
by default, right?
So if you go into Google
Cloud Compute Engine,
you spin up a disk, you spin
up an image or a snapshot,
and you just have all
the default parameters,
we will encrypt that for
you automatically at rest,
no questions asked, using
our world-class encryption
methodologies, right?
So you don't have
to worry about it.
You just go ahead and spin
it up, encrypted at rest.
Now, we know that some
of you, as our customers,
you maybe work in
industries, like banking,
or financial services, or
consulting where you're
expected or you're
legally obligated to have
some more rigor or more control
in how your data is protected
at rest, right?
And so as a result of that, we
give you some more options here
to give you more control over
how your data is actually
encrypted.
So I'll talk about
that middle one next.
And this is a thing that we
call customer-managed encryption
keys.
And so here what
you do is, right,
you create a key in
another GCP service
called Cloud Key
Management Service.
So you create that key.
And then when you create
a disk, or an image,
or a snapshot in GCE, what we
go ahead and do is we ask you,
hey, which one of
these keys do you
want to use to actually
protect this content, right?
And so here you are deferring
the creation and the storage
of the keys to GCP,
but you're still
in full control of the
lifecycle of that key.
You can revoke access.
You can disable the key.
You can delete it,
et cetera, right?
And then finally, on
the very right there,
we have another
option called customer
supplied encryption keys.
And so in this
case, what happens
is we just ask you for the key.
And Google Cloud is
actually deferring
the creation and storage of
the key to you, the customer,
right?
So this gives you full control.
When you create the
disk, for example,
we ask you for the key.
We obviously don't
store it, but we
use it to encrypt your content.
And the next time that disk
is used, say a VM startup,
we go ahead and ask you
for that key again, right?
So this is full control.
And this is really
popular, again,
in some of those verticals
like banking, ok?
Switching gears a little--
actually, just kidding.
Continuing on, like
most features in GCE,
these controls are
available to you in the UI,
in the command
line, or in the API.
So here I'm going
to show you, just
for simplicity's
sake, what it looks
like in the UI, what these three
options look like in the UI.
So here, this is the
VM Creation Page.
This is, when you
create a VM, we
ask you to create to
boot disk, of course.
And you can actually select
either the automatic option
on the far left where no
questions asked, we just
go ahead and do it for you.
In the middle,
you'll see the option
to specify a key in
Key Management Service.
So that dropdown is a set
of keys you have there.
And then on the
far right, that's
the customer-supplied
option where
we ask you what the key is.
You input it in that
box and you go ahead.
So the take away here
really is that, however you
want to manage how your data
is encrypted at rest, we may
we make it really easy
for you to get started
and to get going with that.
So switching gears a little
bit, another question
that we get asked at Google
Cloud a lot is, well, hey,
you guys are
administering our data.
How much access do
you have to it, right?
Are you reading it constantly?
So we know a lot of you may
have sensitive data in our cloud
that you trust us with.
We know many of
you may also have
auditors who ask the
same question, right,
as part of doing their job.
And so here, the first
thing I want to start with
is, at Google Cloud, right,
we do not access your data
for any other reason
other than to fulfill
our contractual
obligations to you, ok?
So that means whenever
there's a data access event,
right, whenever someone
goes to access your data,
it has to have a very strong
business justification.
And it has to be in line with
that particular statement.
They are fulfilling our
contractual obligations to you.
You can go online again.
You can google
access transparency,
and you can find out the
well-defined set of sub reasons
for why we access your data.
And it turns out by far
the most common one,
I think over 95% of
these access events
happen because our
customers, you guys,
asked us to access your data as
part of, say, a support case,
right?
But on top of that,
you don't have
to take our word for it, right?
Whenever Google
accesses your data,
we'll create an audit log
for you in near real time,
right, so that you can hold us
accountable to that statement
there, right?
So let's take a quick
look at one of those audit
logs looks like.
The font's probably
a little small,
so I'll just walk through this
audit log for those of you
maybe in the back who can't see.
So the first thing
you'll see is this
is just a standard audit log.
But it's created when an
access event happens, when
a Google access event happens.
And the first thing you'll
see highlighted in yellow
there is we give you a reason
why we access your data.
It aligns to one
of the sub reasons
for fulfilling our contractual
obligations to you.
And so here you see
this is actually
a customer-initiated
support request.
And we even give
you the case number
so that you can follow up,
understand why exactly we're
accessing your data.
Here, likely it's
because you asked us to.
And then in green,
you see we give you
a lot of information
around, what exactly
did Google do with your data
during this access event,
right?
So which method did we call?
Which resource
did we call it on?
How long did it take?
What project did it happen
in, et cetera, right?
And so this is really
aligning with our goal,
with our principle of making
it really transparent in how
we administer our platform
and giving you, our customers,
the tools to hold us
accountable for that, right?
Ok, so that brings
us to the end.
Just to quickly
summarize, right,
we talked through six
steps for best practices
in Compute Engine.
I see a lot of you
are taking pictures.
I just want to remind
you all that this,
like all talks at
Google Cloud Next,
is going to be
posted to YouTube.
So you can go, watch
that, drill into one
of the steps that
was particularly
interesting to you,
et cetera, right?
And the final thing I
want to leave you all with
is this, right?
Google Cloud, like
the rest of Google,
we take security and privacy
incredibly, incredibly
seriously, roight?
So we're constantly improving.
And we're really, really
receptive to feedback, right?
So please-- we've
worked with Two Sigma.
We want that to be the
rule, not the exception.
We're really open to
working with you all.
We want to make
sure that what we're
doing aligns with your needs.
And we want to make sure
we address any gaps, right?
So leave us feedback.
Go to User Voice.
Go to the Developer Console.
Leave us feedback about this
or really any other features.
It really does help
influence our backlog,
influence our decisions, right?
So with that, thank
you all very much.
I hope you have a good
rest of your time here.
[THEME MUSIC PLAYING]